in 2015 right after i became governor um
we had i had only been governor for 89
days and we had the worst violence in 47
years break out in our largest city in
baltimore after the death of freddie
gray
and uh you know in the very first few
hours
in baltimore city 400 businesses were
burned and looted and destroyed
127 police and firefighters were injured
and hospitalized
the the city police force was
overwhelmed
and the city was really having you know
no ability to respond
it was it was sort of out of control
[Music]
let's talk about the other thing that's
going on because there is
another thing going on there's always a
lot of things but there's sort of two
main ones going on at the moment and and
the second one obviously
is i guess the best way you you'd
describe it
is either the racial unrest or the
protesting or the rioting just the whole
conversation we're having the
the toppling of of monuments now again
you're in maryland
dc's right there awful lot of monuments
awful lot of history is right in your
backyard
um you know you've got you've got
baltimore there which has its own set of
set of problems um so i'm not even going
to ask you a question i'm just going to
i'm going to just pass all that off to
you take it away yeah
yeah well that was that's we're just
going to let me tee it up and
um what so i i you know you look at the
title of the book it's like
riots you know cancer riots a global
pandemic
i i dealt with this and i talk about
this a lot and there's real parallels to
what's going on right now with the
the riots the the violence the the
unrest the protests
uh what however you want to describe
there's a little bit of all of that
going on across america in different
cities
um in 2015 right after i became governor
we had i i'd only been governor for 89
days and we had the worst violence in 47
years break out in our largest city in
baltimore after the death of freddie
gray
and uh you know in the very first few
hours
in baltimore city 400 businesses were
burned and looted and destroyed
127 police and firefighters were injured
and hospitalized
the the city police force was
overwhelmed and the city was really
having you know no ability to respond it
was it was sort of out of control
and as governor i declared a state of
emergency
sent in 4 000 members of the national
guard and a thousand police officers
into the city
we allowed peaceful protests to go on
for a week but we shut down the violence
we stopped the burning
the looting and all the damage that was
being done
and you know i write about this extent i
think five chapters on this in the book
i walk the streets of baltimore for a
solid week to listen to people
i was hugging people who lost their
businesses in their homes i was
meeting with community leaders i was
talking to faith-based leaders i was
i was walking the streets where freddie
gray's neighborhood i was
you know i was dealing with the crisis
but also
trying to lower the temperature um
and i think we found the balance of i
call it you know reagan's piece through
strength we sent enough
people in there to keep the citizens
safe to not allow the violence and
destruction
without further inflaming you know the
the the anger and violence by moving too
aggressively
you know we just you know if you were
protesting in the streets
it was okay if you're throwing rocks and
setting things on fire
we're going to arrest you and i think
the mistakes that were made in some of
the large cities today by just letting
you know mob rule take over and and just
not to respond at all is a big mistake
there are obviously
legitimate frustrations in the black
community and i i was very proud of
actually baltimore this
this time as we're seeing things erupt
everywhere it was mostly
very peaceful protests without the
violence and destruct destruction this
time and
and i think our our police state police
national guard and city police and
baltimore did a really good job and
i think the citizens here did a good job
they were actually pointing out the
handful of
you know violent folks that weren't even
from the city uh and saying hey
stop this they wanted to just peacefully
express their
their frustrations but it's it's
something we've got to get a handle on
and i
you know i understand both sides of the
argument but i i i talk about this
extensively in the book i think you've
gotta
you know you've got to find the way to
get this under control
while addressing some of the concerns
how miserable of it
of a decision is it for you when
something's going down in one of your
cities in this case baltimore
where you have to then bring in the
national guard or something else where
i know it's your preference to let the
mayor hopefully do his or her job and
make sure that they take care of
business but as we're seeing in a lot of
these states right now i mean we're
really seeing it in portland right now
the the mayor seems either unwilling or
unable to
to do anything and and now we've got
we've got in effect we've got federal
troops
in the streets of portland yeah it's uh
they're making the um
the mayor i think by not taking action
early
i think they they made a mistake and i
it wasn't uh
you know i i had i was very prepared for
that i kind of saw
what might be happening our team that's
we stood up the maryland emergency
management agency
in about a week in advance we saw things
potentially bubble up a couple days
earlier
i was ready with an executive order you
know already prepared i've been in
constant contact with the city
it's the first violence that broke out i
was on the phone with the mayor
uh saying you know this doesn't look
like you have it under control
i took action within a matter of hours
uh to come in
and and and back up the beleaguered
police that were
overwhelmed in the city and i think you
know that early and aggressive action
again it's sort of like this pandemic
there's no time to delay and hesitate
and to be too passive um but again we we
didn't go in there and aggressively
you know you know cause you know further
escalation of the problem
we just went in there to keep the
citizens safe and they're very
appreciative of it
um you know the people in baltimore were
like thank you because they were scared
they were really worried about this
violence and the people trying to take
over their city
are you hearing from just regular people
that they're really worried about the
sort of mob
rule that seems to be taking effect
regardless of whether your first statue
stands
the fact that they are just coming down
all over the place
um as opposed to let's you know let's
vote
and make a decision or have you know
some some process related to the law i
mean
whether you want them down or not i
think most people agree that tearing
them down
is not legal at the very at the very
least do our regular people bringing
that up to you that the rule of law
seems to be
uh up in the air at the moment well to
me
i'm shocked that this is even a debate
really
uh i mean we had we did have although i
was praising uh baltimore this time
about the lack of violence we did have a
situation where
uh in little italy we had that somebody
a smaller group of folks tore down a
christopher columbus statue
now i'm not here to debate the merits of
whether christopher columbus was a great
guy or not but there's no way
that we should uh encourage you know
mobs to be able to tear down whatever
piece of art or history that they want
to
instead of going before the city council
and arguing why they think they maybe
should you know put that in a museum or
do something
else we actually had a city councilman
member in baltimore while they were
tearing down that statue that tweeted
something like
you know maybe they should consider
going down and tearing down another
statue
that was built to honor fallen police
officers
a memorial that was put up by the
families of i mean it was just
unbelievable that we're having these
kinds of discussions i i understand the
debate about some
some of these statues maybe we really
should take a look at you know
making a decision to remove them and i
think that's a debate that's an argument
and discussion we definitely should have
um and some of them i understand why
they're they may be offensive to some
folks but you can't just allow mobs to
decide which ones they want to tear down
yeah well we seem to be in this sort of
mob
mob moment i suppose you could call it
um
what are you seeing between the the
tension right now between the
republicans and the democrats
you strike me as what i would say is a
pretty moderate republican
um you can you can either you can assess
that statement however
however you'd like but that's what you
strike me as um what what i'm worried
about is that you know i don't know how
much you know about me but i was
i was a lifelong democrat lefty
progressive
until the last couple of years and i
know
and then you saw the light and here we
are right and here we are
but but what i am worried about is that
my my former side so to speak and i
don't like doing it in sides but
you know there's only so many ways we
can talk about these things that my
former side that it seems like if you
don't go
fully woke if you don't go fully to
where the bernie
aoc energy is
that they're just going to take you out
and are are you seeing that at a state
level too
oh yeah no there's no question about
that and so yeah i look i
i'm a lifelong uh republican i was a
chairman of youth for reagan and i was
in
you know i would say most of my life i
would be considered a conservative
republican and now i guess they call me
a moderate because you know i i i really
try to avoid the extremes of either
party and
i think one of the problems we have
today is that you know
first of all i like to avoid the
divisive angry rhetoric and because i
want to work together to get things done
that makes me a moderate i guess
i don't think um you know trying to get
things done
and finding compromise you know is the
dirty word
compromise isn't a bad thing if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell